e aí
e as coisas só ganham sentido quando nós
as conhecemos o que você conhece até
onde já foi conhece o teu irmão a tua
irmã ou prefere deixar para depois
e quem você conhece com quantos já
conversou conhece as histórias as
consequências is how é mais fácil
apontar quem errou o diálogo é a face
humana do conflito somente quando eu
chego ao outro transpondo a barreira do
rito é que eu vejo que é mais dele em
mim do que é capaz de expressar o
veredito somos todos os recuperandos o
que nos difere esse já conhecemos ou não
o amor pois quem já amou e foi amado
percebeu que não mais nos cabe a dor
afinal se o meu erro me definir nem do
amanhã eu vou precisar o erro não é uma
etiqueta é apenas luz sobre o que deve
mudar por isto carrega o amor caso o
amor ele não exista seja o inventor é
dando amor que se recebe recupere por
onde for
e as coisas só ganham sentido quando nós
as conhecemos esse é o título do poema
que eu fiz para o senhor mário ottoboni
que faleceu ano passado e o mário tomou
de representa muito para mim porque ele
fundou uma instituição carcerária se
chama apac associação de proteção e
assistência ao condenado e essa
instituição transformou de uma forma bem
legal a minha vida o mário ottoboni
prega que somos todos maiores que os
nossos erros e essa mensagem que eu
quero passar aqui hoje somos todos os
maiores que os nossos erros o erro não é
uma etiqueta é apenas luz sobre o que
deve mudar
olá eu sou professor de oratória e nessa
caminhada e pela minha experiência no
presídio eu comecei a fazer algumas
associações essa experiência consistiu
no no final da minha graduação em
direito eu tive a oportunidade de passar
uma semana emerso e uma instituição
carcerária eu dormia acordava jogava
bola almoçava jantava perdi e ganhava no
xadrez discutia conversava e foi muito
bom para eu entender e compreender se eu
fosse lá julgar eu acho que eu ia ter
perdido meu tempo mas para entender
entender e conhecer foi muito rico essa
experiência e essa experiência começou a
me mostrar que realmente somos todos
maiores que os nossos erros né tituição
não há armas não há câmeras os
recuperandos como são chamados os presos
é que tem a chave da cela existe um
critério para escolha deles mas são eles
e me perguntaram uma vez você não tem
medo
um lugar em que funciona dessa forma e a
resposta que eu dei foi o presídio
convencional ele é regido pela vingança
pelo medo lá é regido pelo amor e nos
muros da ataque eu já li a mensagem de
que do amor ninguém foge isso fez muito
sentido para mim a relação que eu faço
uma oratória que eu comecei a falar é
que existe uma regra dos 3 dedos que
quando eu aponto o dedo para alguém para
fazer um julgamento existem três dedos
apontando para mim o que que relaciona
com a oratória o modo como eu julgo uma
pessoa encarcerada é o modo como eu
julgo um erro e o modo como eu julgo um
erro é o modo como eu me coloco
imposição de compaixão ou não a ele
a história aqui na frente pisar nesse
tapete se comunicar é um convite aberto
para o erro se eu não tiver em paz com
ele essa atividade ela se torna bem gata
que que é o erro na minha concepção o
erro ele é uma fotografia mental que a
gente faz de uma expectativa eu espero
que isso se dê da seguinte forma quando
isso realmente se dá quando isso se
realiza temos um fato e quando a gente
tira uma nova fotografia desse novo fato
e sobrepõe antiga da expectativa a
grande maioria das vezes vai haver
alguma discrepância racionalmente é uma
discrepância só que a sociedade eu não
sei porque começou a atribuir um valor a
essa discrepância e um valor negativo o
valor pejorativo porque isso é
pernicioso porque isso faz mal o que ao
erro que antes a gente poderia conceber
como oportunidade
bom e até um apontamento para o caminho
certo a gente começou atribuir um peso
uma carga negativa e se eu vejo dessa
forma quando eu venho para cá falar e eu
não tô em paz com esse erro eu começo a
ficar extremamente tenso essa atenção
ainda falando de oratória ela vem de um
transbordar o que a gente faz chegar ao
outro na nossa comunicação é o que
transborda na gente se eu venho para cá
e transbordo leveza eu alcanço leveza e
vocês se eu venho para cá e transbordo
confiança segurança essa segurança e
essa confiança chegam à vocês isso se
relaciona também com a regra dos 3 dedos
né o que alcance o outro é o que
transborda em mim e quando eu venho para
cá seja na vida ou na oratória eu busco
sempre transbordar a generosidade
generosidade no sentido de que eu vou
e entregar tudo que eu tenho de bom na
comunicação e também uma confiança na
generosidade no sentido de que eu
acredito que quando eu entrego tudo que
eu tenho eu vou encontrar tudo o que se
tem que que significa eu venho para cá
leve eu tava nervoso ali mas eu fiquei
repetindo para mim generosidade
generosidade eu vou me lançar lá com
coração tão bom que eu vou encontrar
coisas boas faça um teste isso de fato
acontece e depois que eu comecei a virar
as chavinhas da minha cabeça o processo
de comunicação começou a ser mais grato
mais assertivo mais feliz
e esse erro ele me faz visitar uma época
lá na minha cidade é uns nove anos atrás
eu estudava em uma escola e existem
várias semelhanças entre o sistema
punitivo escolar e sistema punitivo
penal nesta escola um rapaz ele tava
tendo diversos tipos de transgressões
com a norma semanalmente ele era chamada
na diretoria os pais dele choravam por
achar que era um erro não saber como
lidar com aquela criança que ele
pré-adolescente até o ponto em que as
transgressões se a vamos lar um tanto
foi necessário fazer uma reunião nessa
escola reuniram todos os professores
reuniram diretores coordenadores e uma
sala não cabia a gente sentada tinha
gente em pé já até um advogado para
decidir como se daria a expulsão daquele
rapaz
e esse rapaz era eu e nesse dia eu pude
vivenciar um perdão que foi quando um
professor meu se levantou e acreditou em
mim acreditou na minha pessoa acreditou
que ali alguém era maior que o próprio
erro
e foi decidido que eu seria suspenso e
esse perdão externo que vivenciei seja
na escola seja em casa aqui mesmo
turbulentos eu encontrei meu pai e minha
mãe que felizmente estão aqui hoje dando
esse sorriso maravilhosos para mim eu
pude vivenciar um perdão externo tão
grande que foi o contrário dos três
dedos eu vivenciei isso apontou para mim
eu comecei a vivenciar o perdão interno
eu vi que eu era maior do que o meu
próprio erro
não existe uma correlação entre expulsão
e transgressão criminal o meu tcc na
graduação de direito meu trabalho de
conclusão de curso foi sobre o sistema
punitivo escolar eu fazia mediações de
conflitos escolares semanalmente uma
história uma escola estadual aqui de
lavores e eu ia lá lidar com os
christians de alguns anos atrás e e é
incrível eu perceber como que a vivência
na tá que me sensibilizou para ver seres
humanos onde as vezes muita gente ver
com o termo mas realmente animais como
eu era visto também na minha época de
escola eu fui levar esse perdão externo
fui levar essa minha maturidade que eu
fui ressignificando muita coisa e a
minha mensagem aqui hoje é que a gente
possa ressignificar o erro tive esse
episódio na escola 9 anos depois eu
estava dentro de um presídio dessa vez
como visitante tudo isso começou
olá seja na minha cabeça que realmente o
erro ele não é uma etiqueta ele é luz
sobre o que pode mudar essa mesma
caminhada eu comecei a desenvolver um
treinamento de oratória para ajudar os
recuperandos e as recuperadas a
protagonizar a mensagem que eles têm
todos nós temos mensagens para
transmitir inclusive eles e elas e esse
treinamento era para empoderá-los
ajudá-los com questões mais técnicas
questões mais humanas questões
comunicativas eu comecei a debruçar
sobre isso comecei a me apaixonar com
isso e o resultado foi que há dois anos
eu montei um negócio de impacto social
eu vendo para empresas mais fácil esse
trabalho social no presídio que é o de
levar comunicação e perdão externo para
essas pessoas
e de alguma forma quando alguém não
apenas eu mas quando alguém entra no
presídio e olha com amor para essas
pessoas elas experimentam um amor esse
amor entra e esse amor vai sair e a
gente tem que pensar sempre que as
pessoas que estão cumprindo pena elas
voltam seja filosofia que você quiser
admitir na sua vida pense nisso isso a
gente entender que as pessoas são
maiores que os próprios erros todo mundo
ganha
é a coisa sobem o sentido quando nós nos
conhecemos o que você conhece até onde
já foi conhece o seu irmão sua irmã ou
prefere deixar para depois
aí sim você conhece com quantos já
conversou conhece as histórias as
consequências ou é mais fácil apontar
quem errou o diálogo é a face humana do
conflito somente quando chego ao outro
transpondo a barreira do rito é que vejo
que a mais dele em mim do que é capaz de
expressar o veredito somos todos
recuperamos o que nos difere é que já
conhecemos ou não o amor pois quem já
amou e foi amado percebeu que não mais
nos cabe a dor e eu erro me definir nem
do amanhã vou precisar o erro não é uma
etiqueta e apenas luz sobre o que devo
mudar por isso carregue o amor caso amor
ele não exista veja o inventor é dando
amor que se recebe recupere por onde for
essas baixas elas
e o ataque estava tendo batizado nesse
dia e é bom que a gente entender que as
pessoas que estão cumprindo pena elas
são iguais a nós olha para o lado vejo
que o seu sorriso nosso sorriso é igual
sorriso de um recuperando que aparece
ali meu pai e meu irmão tão nessas
imagens e fica difícil saber quem tá
cumprindo pena quem é o meu pai quem é o
meu irmão e essa ideia não há diferença
somos todos maiores que os nossos erros
ekartolle diz que a vida vai nos dar a
oportunidade mais útil para a evolução
da nossa consciência por isto carrega o
amor caso amor ele não exista seja o
inventor
e é dando amor que se recebe recupere
por onde for
g1